welcome to more logic I plan to make
this the last installment in my brief
introduction to using logic as a way of
looking at language if you haven't gone
through the previous videos one through
four please take time to do so go ahead
I'll wait for you before getting into
the new topics I'm going to offer a
brief note on translating into logic I
realized that I never took the time to
break translations into a step-by-step
process now it's a good time to slow the
pace down a bit and work through how to
parse ordinary language in logical
language then translate that logical
language into symbolic logic first make
sure you understand the logic of the
sentence you're analyzing if your
sentence is English is a tough language
break it down you're actually saying
that English is tough in that English is
language similarly a good person is
somebody who's both good and a person
then break the translation in stages
first reword the sentence and logical
language English is a tough language
becomes English is tough and English as
the language once you've structured it
clearly start putting the sentence into
logic figure out how many variables you
have and where to use them for all X if
X is English then X is tough and X is
length which is a good example as you go
through this process look for buzzwords
you've learned logical operators for
if-then if and only if and or and so on
figure out where those go also pick out
Universal and existential terms always
and anytime een for all times somewhere
is for some place and so on so the logic
of everybody's talking to everybody else
is more transparent once it's reworded
all persons are talking to all other
persons it's just a step from there to
for all X for all Y if X is a person and
Y is a person then X is talking to Y
now I fully realized that just throwing
three or four heuristics out your way
isn't going to help you translate in
detail into logic so I'm going to offer
a few links in the info bar below that
should provide you with further
exercises and more information on this
topic under the new stuff I mentioned
the domain of discourse when talking
about variables I said that it was the
set of all things a variable could
represent that brings up two concepts we
haven't covered yet a set and members of
a set in logic a set is just a grouping
of things that belong together
there's a set of colors of paint a set
of ingredients in ice cream a set of
people whose company you enjoy those
things within that set are its members
members of the set of ingredients in ice
cream include eggs cream and sugar if
something a is an element of set a its
residents represented this way so eggs
are an element of the set ice cream
ingredients we can also say that some B
is not an element of set a for example
mutton is not an element of the set of
ice cream ingredients but consider that
some members of ice cream ingredients
are also members of the set of dairy
products so the two sets intersect each
other
ice cream ingredients intersects dairy
products that's the intersection of the
two sets you can also speak of the union
of the two sets this is the same concept
underpinning logical or the union of ice
cream ingredients and dairy products
includes every member of both sets let's
get a little more detailed here there
aren't simply sets sets may have subsets
so ice cream ingredients are a subset of
foods but what we really mean by this is
that ice cream ingredients and foods are
two different sets so it's even more
precise to call ice cream ingredients a
proper subset of the set of foods of
course two sets can also coincide the
set of ice cream ingredients may be
exactly the same as the set of
ingredients for something I've never
heard of before in which case every
member of one would be a member of the
other switching gears here to
probability I'm not going to look at
solving problems in probability this is
just about the
the logic the language of probability
all right keep the concepts you just
learned about for sets in mind here the
probability of a single event a is
represented as the probability of a a
separative event B has a probability B
now think back to our sets taking both
the probability of a or the probability
of B and that's illogical or there
you'll have the probability of the union
of a and B and you can bring back the
concept of intersection to here it's the
probability of both a and B being true
now if you think that the probability of
event a depends on event B you'll talk
about the probability of a on B likewise
if the probability of B depends on a
then that's the probability of B on a as
I've mentioned this is all well and good
for the probably the language of
probability but if you want to calculate
probabilities you'll need more
information than the symbols I've given
you well those are all the topics I have
to cover in this quick run through the
basics of using logic as a way for
understanding language of course logic
covers so many subjects and has so many
uses that I haven't even touched on in
these videos it's heavily influenced
many fields with mathematics philosophy
computer science and more but crucial to
those studies is logical validity
instead the heart of this course has
been the use of logic to understand
sentences language I hope that this
short introduction to formal logic will
help me take a structure to look at
language and provide you with a good
jumping-off point for learning more as
always I appreciate your time and thank
you for learning with me